[Applause]
heat and anticipation levels at fever
pitch the fans who follow Andy Murray
around the world in Melbourne to see him
compete at the Australian Open for one
final time I have found a way audience
Arjun eight it was his last match you're
an adequacy walk to me I watched the
daughter park in New Zealand going down
without a fight was never an option for
the 31 year old trailing two sets in in
obvious pain others might have faded
away but bloody-minded as ever he fought
back taking the Spaniard Roberto
Bautista ague to a fifth set almost in
tears as his ailing body started to
defeat him the stage was set for Murray
to announce his immediate retirement but
Murray said he was still unsure whether
to have more surgery on his troublesome
hip it's a really big operation you know
it's a common operation but it's a big
one and not an easy thing to recover
from so there's you know a chance by
having that that I'm not able to play
again do you think there has been a
failure to capitalize on the success of
your career you know I would have liked
during this period it'd be nice like
when you finish playing you can loop
back and go yeah look tennis has become
a bigger sport is more popular there's
more children playing more chorus and
such and such and my understanding is
that that's not the case in many ways
this match encapsulated
the courage which has defined Andy
Murray's career a street fighter with a
never-say-die attitude now in the final
throes of his career and all following
factory Laskey a minute ago
you could tell he was sore he was really
struggling a little bit at the end and
tired but even stole some of the shorts
for soup here no matter what happens
he's always going to be on here arguably
the greatest British athlete of a
generation bowing out but the fans hope
he will be back for a final Wimbledon
farewell Martha Kellner Sky News
Melbourne